RICHARD WEI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name's Richard Wei, and I'm
from the Google Brain Team.
Today, let's talk about Swift.
So traditionally,
there are two ways
of building models in Python.
One way is graph building.
The users are required to
explicitly build a graph
and run it and pass it
to a session at runtime.
And the other way
is eager execution.
Eager execution allows
you to write everything
in the source code, and you
interpret it line by line.
And it's really easy to use.
But there's a tension
between graph execution
and eager execution.
Graph execution has
great performance,
but it's not very easy
to use, especially when
it comes to control flow.
Eager execution is
super easy to use
but can be challenging to
achieve high performance,
like graph execution.
Well, can we combine
usability and performance?
Well, what we are
building is something
that combines the ease of
use with high performance
for your machine learning code.
But to do that, we have to
do something more than just
writing a new library.
We had to innovate in
the programming language.
Machine learning is
so important to us
that we're willing to adopt
a programming language
and entire software stack.
Since we need
first-class machine
learning capabilities
and primitives,
not only do we need the ease
of use and high performance,
we also need an
open design process
driven by an established
community for the language.
This brings us to the
Swift programming language.
Swift is a fast, modern
programming language
and is super easy to use.
It's cross-platform, has a
clean syntax like Python,
and it has all the
powerful capabilities,
like type inference,
optionals, and supports
functional programming and
all the great features.
So what exactly is
Swift for TensorFlow?
Well, the key components
of Swift for TensorFlow
is just a magical tensor type.
You can write anything
using tensors.
As you would expect, you can
initialize a tensor like this,
like Python.
Or you can use a full
power generics to power
your models, libraries,
and applications.
Well, math operators,
like sigmoid and matmul
are type saved generic
functions in Swift,
without the need of name
spacing when you use them.
When you combine things
together, it's nice and clean.
The programming style looks just
like Python's eager execution.
Well, as you see,
tensor just works
and is part of the TensorFlow
library, written in Swift.
However, it works very
differently from other language
bindings because
TensorFlow, while tensor
is supported as a first-class
citizen in the programming
language.
For this, we built a technology
called graph program extraction
in the Swift compiler.
In addition to the
ability to treat tensors
as first-class
citizens, we also need
the ability to
train models using
automatic differentiation.
It's graph program extraction,
using automatic differentiation
and do interesting
things even with Python
through interoperability.
Well, all of these components
are integrated natively
in the Swift
programming language,
providing great productivity
for a developer.
So let's start with
a TensorFlow library.
The TensorFlow library has all
the common APIs like the Tensor
API and data API.
In data API, you can
use dataset initializer.
You can use functional zip
and batch operations just
like TF data in Python.
Well in addition to nice-looking
TensorFlow APIs defined
in Swift, you also have access
to all the raw TensorFlow
APIs like this.
Tensor code sits alongside
the rest of the Swift program,
just like eager
execution, and it
interacts with arbitrary
user-defined data structures
in algorithms.
But will it actually
execute line
by line, one
statement at a time,
just like eager execution?
Well, the answer is no.
The TensorFlow library
works quite differently
from all the language bindings.
Swift for TensorFlow is
a full-fledged compiler,
and it makes our code run
fast without sacrificing
the ease of use.
The technology is called
graph program extraction.
So how does it work?
Well, we want users to write
code like eager execution,
but we also want it to
graph level performance.
And we want to support
native language control flow
so your control flow
like ifs and whiles
can be compiled directly
to a TensorFlow graph.
We want the compiler
to handle data transfer
between the device
or between devices,
between the device and the host.
So the burden is now on the
compiler, not on the developer.
Developers don't even
have to think about it.
So this is how it works.
Well, dataset operations such as
zip and batch work as well as--
well, they work in a graph.
Tensor operations such
as matmul can also
be represented as a graph.
When Swift compiler
sees the code,
the Swift compiler automatically
turns this into a graph
by identifying all the
graph-extractable operations.
So Swift compiler
compiles this code,
compiles the
graph-extractable operations
into a TensorFlow graph.
And that will be
part of the binary
that Swift compiler
produces so it's one graph.
At the same time since
it's compiling the graph,
it produces error messages
before even running your code
and catches some shape errors
and all the type errors.
Now with graph
program extraction,
we can combine
performance and usability.
But often in machine
learning code,
we also need to be able
to differentiate code
in train models.
Well, that's one
of the key things
in machine learning algorithm.
A common way to do that
is to take advantage
of automatic differentiation.
Although most automatic
differentiation tools
are an implement
as a library, we
want to take full advantage
of being able to improve
a programming language.
So we build automatic
differentiation
also into the compiler.
So automatic
differentiating in Swift
works on custom data structures.
It works on
TensorFlow, as well as
lots of standard library
functions and standard library
types.
And as a user, you can
define your own type
to be differentiable.
For example, you can define
arbitrary structs, enums,
and other data types and make
them represent a vector space.
And they suddenly
become differentiable.
So the core of the system
is a differential operator.
This is actually
a keyword in Swift
because we've built
that into the language.
For example, we have a 32-bit
floating point operation.
It's a function.
And to differentiate
its function,
we just throw a
differential operator at it.
And we get a gradient,
and we can call it.
It's all functional.
The same thing
applies to tensors.
I have a tensor
inference function
that computes a prediction.
I can throw a differential
operator at it.
I can get the prediction
by calling it,
and I can also get the gradient
of it and apply the gradient.
And I can use a code
like this for training.
Swift also supports
custom gradients.
This is a commonly
requested feature.
Well for example, we
have a times operator,
and we want to apply some
custom gradient on it.
All we have to do is to use
a differentiable attribute
to specify the reverse mode
adjoint for this function.
So when automatic
differentiation sees the code,
it'll automatically
call into the adjoint
when it's differentiating
data flow.
Well, because automatic
differentiation
is language-integrated, it
shows the errors at compile time
when you're differentiating
some non-differentiable function
with cursors pointing exactly
at each non-differentiable
operation in the call stack.
It's really useful.
And also in the future, we plan
to support showing warnings
for numeric stability.
So all of this is
enabled by having
automatic differentiation
built into the compiler.
But since advanced
automatic differentiation
is immensely useful for
machine learning research,
we have support for
arbitrary control flow,
including loops and recursion.
And control flow can also
enable differentiating
through all the tree
data structures defined
using the algebraic
data type in Swift.
And we'll also support
APIs from manipulating
gradient of some
variables, compile time
warning for numeric
ability, and the ability
to compute forward-mode
Jacobian vector
products and full Jacobians.
Well, with all the
features providing
a super easy-to-use
programming interface in Swift,
we also care a lot
about the ecosystem.
Since a machine
learning ecosystem
relies on a lot of
Python libraries,
we don't want to
lose the ability
to call into Python libraries
and use them in Swift.
For that, we built Python
interoperability in Swift.
You can import a Python
library using Python import.
It's like Python.
And you can use numpy
using Python syntax.
Users can directly import their
favorite libraries directly
in Swift and use them as if
they were writing Python.
This gives great compatibility
with the entire machine
learning ecosystem.
So for Python, you can use
your favorite libraries
like numpy or pickle or
gzip, load some images.
It's that simple.
So Swift supports interpreted
mode, scripting mode,
and Jupyter notebooks.
And you can write
interactive code
as if you're writing Python.
And we are releasing an Iris
tutorial on our website,
and you can follow the
tutorial and try it out.
If you want to participate
in the development,
you can download a development
toolchain from our website.
Everything is open source.
On GitHub/tensorflow/swift,
you can
find our technical
documentation, white papers,
and everything, and we have an
open design process as well.
So this is Swift for TensorFlow.
Thank you everyone.
[APPLAUSE]